hey i'm leslie jr and i'm nicolette
robinson we're here with buzzfeed to
take a quiz
to see how well we actually know each
other
[Music]
check off each of the details you're
absolutely sure you know about
your significant other okay your
birthday birthday
yours is april the 18th is august the
6th that's right i just had one happy
birthday to
me their astrological sign i know this
one is your
aries is the only one that can call leo
on there s-h-r-t
well you know their nickname you have
lots of nicknames but i remember in
college your friends used to call you
nico which i thought was very cute
and your family calls you bleep that out
family business owner their hometown
where they grew up you grew up right
here
and here billy bourne you got that
i'm sorry that's not right no that
doesn't count you're queens new york
born but philly raised
but you're like philly rep rep the
philly yeah
okay born in queens i know that their
favorite movie
favorite movie i'm gonna say father of
the bride part two
oh i love it that's a good one one of
yours
is broadcast news that's good i'll take
it
because like when you get into favorite
movies like they're all tied it's
broadcast news it's the godfather
it's malcolm x they're all tied so i'll
take it their favorite tv show
yours is keeping up with those with that
family no that's wrong
it is a guilty pleasure occasionally i
get no judgment
yours is everybody that's right oh
that's again because they're all
they're all tied it's everybody loves
raymond um it's different world
it's roseanne cheers it's a lot um so
we're taking the point their favorite
band
back when you probably liked bands
probably like spice girls is that right
i loved the spice girls they weren't my
favorite one of them
definitely of the nsync i got it i got
it back
oh you loved um i know which one you
better get it right
let's sing zombie it's called the
cranberries my girl dolores presley that
is 100 my favorite band
your favorite book oh man what is it
called it's one kindred it's called
kindred
that's really good i do love kindred you
have a bunch of favorite books
oh well do you know me i said i knew
you'd be lovely
oh i love that book yeah it's a great
it's a book of short stories i love that
book
by althea black you love the
autobiography of malcolm x dad is my
favorite book
their preferred pizza topping pepperoni
is it hurts
absolutely yours is pepperoni and
sausage and
garlic powder and all the spices on top
i don't like the smell of i will accept
that answer
their coffee order was mine black there
you go
your coffee odor is going to be black
coffee and then you're gonna put
either oat milk or almond milk or
yeah their favorite adult beverage hers
is manhattan
with extra cherries cherries yours
i don't know tequila that's probably
that's that's right he always orders
tequila meat around somewhere and just a
little patron
don't separate me from my tequila i just
want it in a
in a glass that's it their favorite ice
cream flavor
cookies and cream that's one of mine i i
don't know if i have a favorite
i don't discriminate between ice creams
yours is chocolate chip cookies
that is it their favorite
quarantine hobby your favorite hobby has
turned into napping
i don't know if that counts as a hobby
but because yeah i guess it's like
when you get to choose what you do i
choose to nap
your hobby let's say it together to make
sure that they that they know we're
online
one two three cooking yeah very good
they're hidden talent not only the dirty
ones
don't put any of them playing the dirty
ones out there what is your hidden
talent
i can do like kids voices sure does that
count as a hidden talent or does that
just kind of go along with our
craft yeah you also know how to juggle i
do know how to juggle that's a good one
that's one that that's a good one well
you're actually really good at
music history and stuff like you know a
lot about
music i'll take it we're taking it
buzzfeed come and stop us
your mood booster i'm gonna have naughty
answers for this so
okay the non-naughty answer i think i'm
good let's say it together i'm gonna say
yours
one two three
okay
to listen to music was the answer was
the end of the answer but we didn't get
it at the same time so okay so we won't
get it
[Music]
you checked 14 out of 15 on the list
you're an expert
on your significant other thank god i'm
an expert at something
buzzfeed thank you so much for the quiz
we are experts at knowing one another
please
check out love in the time of corona
august 22nd and 23rd
on freeform and then it'll be on hulu
after that
[Music]
you